[Musique]
les shadoks d'en bas protestent les
essais de fusées font trop de bruit à
leur avis ça les gêne c'était pourtant
une fusée de l'ups elle avait un premier
étage pour et de détritus qui devait en
principe servir de combustible un
deuxième étage bourg et d'autres
détritus indispensable pour vivre sur la
terre et dans les interstices
on avait les châteaux elles étaient
munies et des derniers perfectionnements
techniques telles que casseroles à
retardement
le batteur d'air et et tire bouchon
hypersustentateurs la seule difficulté
c'est qu'elle ne marchait que d'un côté
de haut en bas uniquement
c'est pourquoi les shadoks a pensé qu'il
serait intéressant de faire porter la
fusée dans l'espace par les shadoks d'en
bas il avait déjà soutenu la planète
pendant pas mal de temps et porter une
fusée à côté c'est erignac il dit ceux
d'en haut le allait envoyer dépit des
potentiels pour négocier la terre et les
avaient fait descendre par les petits
qu'on dit
je dors pas d'abord s'était trompé les
avez mangés puis il avait répondu tu ne
peux tout de même pas là pour porter
leurs affaires leurs casseroles leurs
armoires leurs détritus et fuji partie
le marché de toute façon qu'ils disaient
ils avaient l'intention de rester ici
pour être enfin tranquille
en réalité c'était pas vrai eux aussi
avaient l'intention de déménager sur la
terre mais par quels moyens
[Musique]